It's a good thing Charlie Hunnam didn't play
Christian Grey.
Turns out, there's one thing the Sons of Anarchy
alum and Triple Frontier star can't stand
to do as part of his job, and it's the one
thing many others might enjoy the most: Charlie
Hunnam hates filming love scenes.
In a 2017 interview with Elle, Hunnam explained
that making out with women on camera isn't
only a lot less glamorous than it appears
to be, but it's also kind of terrifying, due
in part to the fact that he's huge germophobe.
The actor told the publication,
"I've been profoundly germophobic since I
was a young child."
Hunnam shared with Elle that his germophobia
began when he was only eight or nine years
old, after having learned about a parasite
that caused blindness.
He explained,
"There was a parasite from dogs in the north
of England that, if you ingested it, could
turn you blind.
We had a thing in schools to educate the kids
about the importance of hygiene, specifically
around dogs, because we had a few kids who
went blind.
That horrified me."
As an adult, the actor has had a difficult
time getting intimate on screen.
"You'd think that would be the best part of
the job, right?"
"Yeah."
"No.
I wake up in cold sweats that day."
But Hunnam's germophobia is only part of the
reason why he hates shooting love scenes.
He's also keenly aware of the effect his job
as a leading man has on his jewelry designer
girlfriend, Morgana McNelis.
He told Elle,
"I'm in a very committed relationship, and
I'm also cognizant that it's not my girlfriend's
favorite part of my job."
So when Hunnam is forced to feign intimacy,
he does so knowing that there's a fine line
he'll have to walk.
Part of being an actor is making a scene believable,
which means that he has to make a real connection
with the person that he's working with.
But, as he explained to Elle, it's also important
that it's clear that any on-set intimacy is
entirely fabricated — and won't spill over
into the real world.
Hunnam said,
"I try to be sensitive to the fact that we're
doing something intimate, but also keep a
clear boundary […] It's a delicate balance
to strike - to be emotionally open enough
to have an experience that feels honest between
two people but also maintain that it's just
for the film.
It's not my favorite thing to do.
I don't want to kiss anyone but my girlfriend
for my whole life."
Fortunately, Hunnam has never felt objectified
by others in the industry, and has evidently
had an easy enough time getting people to
respect his feelings and understand where
he's coming from regarding love scenes.
When asked if he felt more like an object
to ogle than a living, breathing person, he
said,
"I don't view myself that way.
I obviously am cognizant of the fact that
being handsome gives me greater breadth of
opportunity.
I'd hope that what I bring to the table far
surpasses just being handsome."
So, all things considered, it's probably for
the best that the actor wound up dropping
out of the first 50 Shades of Grey film back
in 2015.
Hunnam had cited scheduling conflicts as the
reason for his departure - he had already
promised to be in Crimson Peak - but perhaps
coming to terms with the full extent of 50
Shades of Grey's romantic content had something
to do with pushing him in that direction.
Either way, Hunnam maintains that having to
let go of playing Grey was a huge disappointment
for him, especially since he had bonded with
the film's director, Sam Taylor-Johnson.
He told Elle,
"That was a somewhat traumatic experience
for me.
I didn't want to open that wound."
Call it germophobia, or call it true love
and an undying commitment to his girlfriend.
Whatever the reasoning, Charlie Hunnam will
likely never be an actor who loves stripping
down with his co-stars.
As he explained,
"The point is, everyone thinks it's great
to be an actor and get to kiss a bunch of
beautiful actresses in films, but I actually
hate it."
"I wouldn't even use my girlfriend's toothbrush.
That's just disgusting."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.